sharpen your axes because it's time to
return to the age of Vikings the second
season of Vikings Valhalla is cresting
the Horizon and we'd all better be
prepared for its attack it seemed
Vikings was at an end when the original
history series concluded in 2020 but it
wasn't long before the show's Creator
Michael Hurst passed the torch to Jeb
Stewart who crossed the streaming Seas
to Netflix and gave us Vikings Valhalla
a sequel series set a century after the
events of its predecessor Valhalla
introduced fans to Prince Harold of
Norway and hero in the making late
Erickson initially wary of one another
the two became allies to change the time
of the Vikings forever of course they've
still got to overcome some obstacles to
get there the first season ended with
live seeing red and Harold on the run
after katigat's fall so their combined
comeback will need to be epic
Netflix offered up a first look at
Vikings Valhalla season 2 during the
streamer's annual to Doom event starting
shortly after the events of the first
season Harold Leif and Freitas are on
the Run only for Olaf to push them back
to the Shoreline thankfully help comes
from above via an unknown Ally is
forkbeard fending for Our Heroes or has
his son King knut turned up at the right
time whoever it is they make an
explosive impact the second season will
debut on January 12 2023 but Netflix
hasn't released any other trailers
keeping things close to the vest the
first season trailers hit only a few
short weeks before the season was
released so the streamer seems to be
taking that approach again to Doom did
offer up this brief synopsis of the
Season though season 2 finds Our Heroes
shortly after the tragic fall of catagat
an event that shattered their dreams and
altered their Destinies finding
themselves suddenly fugitives in
Scandinavia they're forced to test their
Ambitions and courage in Worlds beyond
their familiar fjords showrunner Jeb
Stewart further explained it to Doom
that Harold and Leif will be traveling
down the Nipper River in an adventure he
describes as similar to Thelma and
Louise while Frey greatest will be
heading to the Baltic area of Pomerania
Stewart also promised quite an array of
characters adding we put together this
Motley Crew of nobles Muslim astronomers
and con men and they shove off from
navgron Leo Suter and Sam corlett will
return to lay waste to their enemies as
Prince Harold and Leith Erickson
respectively along with Frida gustavsin
as Freitas Eric's daughter leif's sister
the latter has a crucial path of Rogue
as the last daughter of upsado beyond
that talented Trifecta the show will
also see The Return of Johannes hoker
johannesin as the side-switching
contender for the throne Olaf last seen
threatening katigat and sending its
protectors running Olaf's victory was
short-lived King knut's father King
Swain forthbeard appeared with a fleet
of ships to bring down the treacherous
Tyrant expect all three to be returning
for season 2 along with the surprise
return of Caroline Henderson who played
karagat's Fallen ruler girl Hawkins
speaking to Metro about her character's
demise the Swedish star equipped about
whether she was totally gone from the
series we don't really know that she
might turn up as a ghost or something if
that's not enough Valhalla will also see
the arrival of an MCU star and a
previous punching bag for boxing champ
Adonis Creed Florian montiano of
shangchi and Creed 2 Fame will play the
part of Byzantine General George
maniakis Bradley James of Merlin will
play the leader of a particularly Pagan
bunch of Warriors hiat Camille marqueen
drakinski and Sophia labadeeva have also
joined the cast in an interview with
Digital Spy in February 2022 Jeb Stewart
revealed that even before the first
season's release the second was well
into development and he was dying to get
it out there even before swords were
drawn for the first season of Valhalla
Netflix has given the green light for a
massive 24 episode order assuring that
we'd be seeing Leif and Harold for at
least three seasons
[Music]
foreign